faire penser en faisant danser c'est
l'esprit des compositions dabou cet
artiste et binoy de 42 ans originaire de
trappes prépare son prochain album
afri pop spirit dans son studio il
travaille sur un morceau en particulier
bamako boss
[Musique]
après avoir composé la musique et écrit
son texte à bout que commencer à
enregistrer
c'est le troisième couplet de la chanson
et c'est parti dans la cabine si la
goutte à pita jeter c'est peut-être que
toi même tu a fauté non faut pas faire
ça tapait la doudou sinon le dieu peut
te botter en réalité légaux ce sont les
boss
si tu as le doute montre moi comment tu
peux à coucher grâce à son studio 223
abou peu procédé au mixage
place ensuite à la première écoute et
donc là je vous faire écouter donc après
le travail justement de mx qu'est ce que
cela donne avant le masters et ses
tonalités ses textes sa rythmique
caractérise son style la fripe hop un
genre musical développé depuis 2001
en 2007 il sort son premier ep le
nouveau souffle de la fri pop en 2010
son premier album à free pop color avec
un slogan une musique qui tu ressembles
rassemble et à rien ne ressemble sachant
que l'idée c'est vraiment essayé de
rassembler les personnes qu rassembler
les peuples rassembler les personnes
surtout qu'ils ont au delà ta couleur de
peau ta classe sociale est ta religion
c'est en fait une couleur d'esprit qui
nous rassemble avec des valeurs c'est
vraiment un mélange entre la world music
et la musique urbaine à savoir que moins
chantant fait en français et en bambara
qui est une langue du mali sur des beats
parfois que son hip hop d'autres fins
peu plus at ça donc c'est vraiment un
mélange entrevoir musique et musiques
urbaines à bout peut s'inspirer de
rythme à partir d'une musique pour
ensuite ajouté sa patte
elle avait en effet elle ne rend fou et
laurent d'où je suis sauvé la mise
[Musique]
il faut vraiment être dans mon labo à
pourra faire un petit peu tout est
ensuite envoyé ce que moi j'ai envie de
faire entendre de ma propre création
sans que quelqu'un il ya rajouté quoi
que ce soit qui dénature un peu ce que
j'ai envie de vous présenter la fripe up
c'est aussi aider des jeunes à
développer leur projet musical ce soir à
bourg soit six tirs rappeur d'elancourt
le travail va durer une partie de la
soirée